[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Hello and welcome.
My name is Dustin Kirkland.
I'm a product manager
at Google Cloud.
And I have the
privilege today to speak
with two of my colleagues here,
Justin Santa Barbara, also
an engineer at Google Cloud.
And we have a guest
speaker, a customer of ours,
Twinkle Desai is the VP
of technology at Kohl's.
And she's going to introduce
the concept of multi-cloud
and how that applies
to her organization.
I'll hand this to you, Twinkle.
TWINKLE DESAI: Thank you,
Dustin, for having me.
Thank you guys for
attending this.
So Kohl's is a retailer
and a tech company.
We love technology.
We have huge appetite
to invest in technology
and roll out to our customers.
Our goal is to have a
seamless customer experience.
My team focuses on building
environments and system
to support this ecosystem, which
is resilient, highly available,
highly secure, cost effective.
And we make sure that we
reach out in the industry
to understand the cutting
edge technology, which
can bring value to add
to our goals of having
that seamless
customer experience.
As a retailer,
it's very critical
to make sure we
support the burst
traffic during our peak
holiday season, which is
Black Friday and Cyber Monday.
So to ensure that,
we have a solution,
which is not only cost
effective, secure,
but also low operational cost.
We need to make sure
that the system is
end to end integrated.
At Kohl's, we also ensure
that we are just not
a problem solver, but
also a forward thinker.
So when we talk about
multi-cloud strategy,
we have to ensure that
we meet our checklist.
We came up with an
expectation tree.
It's very important to know what
is a multi-cloud strategy we
want to use and what do we
want to achieve through this.
Our checklist included the
cost effective solution,
secure, highly available,
burst traffic support,
make sure that it's a
centralized operated solution,
so that we don't have to
work with multiple tool sets.
So when we looked
at various products,
for us Anthos, which is
a multi-cloud Kubernete,
seems to be a perfect fit.
And that's where
we started working
on collaborating our
multi-cloud strategy where
we are running multiple payloads
in different cloud solution.
We have 100 plus containers
and 5,000 plus containers
across for stores
and digital strategy,
running 150 plus microservices.
We want to ensure
that we still continue
to deliver that
seamless customer
experience while having the
ability to support the burst
traffic as and when needed.
So Anthos was the
right solution for us.
And currently, we are
working to integrate
the entire payload for digital
and stores on this ecosystem.
I will invite back Dustin to
deep dive into this product
and help us understand
further more.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Thank you, Twinkle.
I think the presentation
that Twinkle gave here really
actually gives us
a good starting
point and a concrete set of
examples where multi-cloud
and having a
multi-cloud strategy is
essential to business
continuity and success
and what it takes to transform
a business that's been around
for a long time to really
operate and operate
well and efficiently
in a truly new era.
And so here, I have
to speak with you
about a handful of
strategies that we think
we can actually help with.
And I'll start here.
This is something that I hear
from every single customer
that I talked to in
2019, a little bit
last year, last year was
a lot about hybrid cloud,
trying to get to a
hybrid cloud point.
And maybe 10 years
before that, it
was just about getting
to cloud at all.
But today, every time I
talk to a technical leader
of any kind in any organization,
the question really comes up,
yeah, Google Cloud is great.
But how do these solutions
fit into a truly multi cloud
architecture?
And I think we can look
at it and start here.
And we can think
about hybrid cloud
as the bridge between
using a public cloud
and a private cloud.
But multi cloud is that
and an extra dimension,
which means actually working
with multiple public clouds,
public clouds that are, in
many cases, competitive.
And that's actually
essential to one
of the tenets of the
multi-cloud architecture.
In this case, last
year at Google Next,
Google took the remarkable
step of bringing GKE on prem
into the enterprise data center.
And now we have quite
a number of customers
up and running with
Google Cloud technology
running inside of their
private cloud environments.
And the response
has been tremendous.
And that's just
the starting point.
That's really just
And I think we'll get
into what that means.
But before we go there,
I want to double down
on Twinkle's display of
the tree, the decision
tree as to why go multi-cloud.
And I've boiled these
down into five or six
points, five or six
bullets, every one
of which we've got
tremendous experience helping
our customers solve one
or more of these problems.
So why multi-cloud?
That might be on
some people's minds.
Maybe if you're
here already, you're
interested in how
Google helps with this.
But let me just make sure
that we start with a taxonomy,
with a set of reasons
and motivations
to ensure that we're
on the same page.
And I'll start at the
top, being able to utilize
more capabilities.
Not every cloud has every
feature as every other cloud.
And in some cases,
you're using one cloud
for a particular
feature or two, and then
another cloud for another.
Now you could take a least
common denominator approach
or greatest common
denominator approach
and ensure that you're
using the greatest
common aspects of
each cloud so that you
have perfect portability.
And that makes sense
for some workloads.
There are other
workloads, though,
that you may want
to really focus in
on a particular offering.
Maybe you've got some
specialized AI ML work,
or you need a very specialized
database, or something else,
OK?
So being able to really tap
into the unique characteristics
of a cloud might
be one reason why
you need to use
more than one cloud,
because maybe your
first cloud didn't
have one aspect or another.
The second is access
to more geographies.
And there are lots of reasons
why you might need access
to another geography.
Some of the customers
I talked to, especially
in the gaming
industry, need to have
their data really close to
the users playing those games.
It's a latency.
It's a law of physics
problem at that point.
Shaving down to milliseconds
or microseconds of latency
is important in the AR,
VR, augmented reality,
virtual reality world, or
some of the gaming world.
But it's not just there.
It's also in banks and fintech.
We see data that cannot move
from one geography to another.
And all of these are reasons
why a multi-cloud approach might
actually be the right answer.
In some cases, it's
a private cloud
running in certain geographies.
In other cases, it's a matter
of using one or more clouds
to supplement those
geographies, being
able to ensure that you can
run those workloads in a place
where one of the public clouds
doesn't exist or doesn't have
a presence.
Now the data gravity
problem is also one
that we hear quite a bit about.
And we see the data gravity
problem across all industries.
I'm working with a couple
of oil and gas companies
where this is really what it's
all about, same with the auto,
and the self-driving
car industry.
There's so much data
that is resident
in one cloud or another.
Meanwhile, there's
other work that
happens in a different
cloud or on prem or in a car
or on a oil rig
or somewhere else.
And yet, crunching that
data close to that data
is essential to these
algorithms even working.
And so having a multi-cloud
strategy to solve the data
gravity problem.
Your data is here,
but something else
needs to happen somewhere else
is another driver for going
multi-cloud.
Reducing vendor
dependency comes in a lot
of different shapes and forms.
In some cases, it's a matter of
having the ability to negotiate
on prices, buy in bulk.
Although, that goes both ways.
Sometimes it's better to
go all in on one cloud
and get as much bulk
discount as possible.
In other cases, just having
multiple vendors is something
that I think we've learned
over the last couple of decades
of enterprise software and
buying software as a service,
sourcing from multiple vendors
certainly gives the buyer
certain advantages.
But it's not just that.
It's also reducing the risk
around one vendor failing
or going down.
Spreading a workload across
multiple clouds and load
balancing across,
that's something
that I've worked with
a number of startups
that grow to a certain
size and then become pretty
essential, too big
to fail, especially
in the transportation
and the financial space.
In which case, you see a
disaster recovery or a failover
scenario with a given workload
or a database being replicated
across multiple clouds.
It's something that
when we get to the demo,
Justin will touch on for sure.
And that resilience to
failure is baked into that.
So it's reducing the
vendor dependency, but also
the dependency on the
things that aren't human,
the machinery underneath,
the network connections,
the distributed denial
of service attack
that might hit one vendor
harder than another vendor,
or at different times perhaps.
And then the last one is
really just as an exercise
in large industry, the result
of mergers and acquisitions.
You buy a company,
and that company
comes with its own dependencies,
its own preferences
for lots of things.
Maybe it's the brand
of office equipment
and chairs in conference rooms.
But that company also comes
with its own preferences
around software as a
service and public cloud
or private cloud as a service.
There's a lot of nuance,
a lot of nuance in each
and every one of these.
I'd ask if to please raise your
hand if at least one of these
did not strike a nerve with
why you would go multi-cloud.
OK, I've successfully gotten
no one to raise their hand.
That's a little anticlimactic.
OK, so now we're going to
move into a second segment
of this talk.
And I'm going to call
this the chalk talk.
I actually created
these slides while I
was watching March Madness,
the NCAA basketball tournament.
And I love basketball.
And I'm always inspired
by a coach that'll
take off their jacket
and really get down
with the team and coach,
coach from the bench.
OK, so now we're
into chalk talk.
And we're going to start
with a couple of formulas.
We're going to do this
as a math chalk talk.
So this isn't a
basketball chalk talk.
This is a math talk chalk talk.
Maybe I'm talking more
to the tech audience
about math than basketball.
I don't know.
I think I cross both of those.
So the formulas start here.
We're going to start
from here and build up.
Containers is
something that I don't
need to explain to
this crowd anymore.
Before five years ago, I think
we would've had to have a,
where did containers come from?
Was Docker first or
Solaris Zones first?
But I think this is all well
understood, well understood
at this point.
And when it comes
to multi-cloud,
there's one thing
that containers
gives you that's absolutely
essential to everything
you want to do in a
multi cloud environment.
And that's portability,
the ability
to move your code, your
workload, your data from one
place to another physical
or virtual or otherwise
from on prem to
the cloud and back
and forth from your developer
laptop in the coffee shop
pushing to the build
system pushing to cloud A,
cloud B, cloud C. When
you fire one vendor
and you buy another vendor,
being able to move that.
And containers are
at the heart of that.
And yes, virtual
machines have always
been able to sort of
move between clouds.
But it's really containers
that got the concept
and boiled it down to its
simplest and most critical
definition, which is an
application, some code that you
bought or you wrote that bundles
its dependencies and everything
it needs to run.
And because it's in that
atomic unit as an image,
it can now move anywhere.
And it was containers
and Docker containers
that really democratized
that technology
and put that into the
hands of everyone.
There were a lot
of companies that
were doing container and
container like things
for decades.
But this really this tectonic
shift in the landscape
happened four or five
years ago, about 2014.
Now once you have a
lot of containers,
like containers to
the containers power,
right, you've now got a problem.
You've got a lot more machines
to manage than you ever
had in the physical
world, more things
to configure than you ever
had in the virtual world.
It's really an exponential,
truly an exponential problem.
And it's Kubernetes that
happened about that same time
four or five years
ago that it actually
provided proper tooling
to be able to handle
that exponentially more
complex scale and scope
that containers introduced
into your enterprise.
I've certainly spoken with
a number of executives
who now look back on that
moment when they realized
they had this problem of
sprawl, sprawl of code,
maybe there were licensing
issues or support issues
or otherwise, and now
being able to manage that
from a single place
where Kubernetes came in
and helped with a lot of that.
Now I think you
know Kubernetes is
built on decades of experience
at Google managing umpteen
illions of containers
over the years on Borg
as jobs as persistent services.
And we've made that
available, made
that available to
the open source
community in the CNCF, the Cloud
Native Computing Foundation,
but certainly as a product
from Google as well.
And that's the Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Now as I alluded to
earlier, last year,
as we tackled the
hybrid cloud problem,
we brought GKE, Google
Kubernetes Engine, which we've
run as a hosted service, managed
service inside of Google Cloud.
We ported that to run inside
of the private data center.
Anywhere that you have a vSphere
with the appropriate number
of physical and
virtual machines,
we can stand up a Google
Kubernetes Engine on prem, GKE
on prem inside of that
enterprise data center.
And we're working
on extending that.
We're working on bringing
that to other environments
as well beyond our starting
point, which we've established.
And it's working really well.
But now we're starting
to gather that feedback
from those initial customers
as to where else they want
to take Google Kubernetes
and use that and use that
elsewhere.
So now you've got a
bunch of Kubernetes,
a bunch of clusters.
And inside of that,
you've successfully
deployed x to the y containers.
And you're scheduling and
scaling them up and down.
And that's great.
So you've actually gone
multi-cloud at this point.
But by this point in
the talk, if you've
followed and
implemented that, you've
now got Kubernetes
running in multiple places
and manage that.
Congratulations.
And you've deployed a bunch
of services into that.
You haven't done that just for
the exercise of doing that.
You've actually
deployed work into each
and every one of those.
And once you've
done that, you now
have services that need
to talk to other services.
You have humans that
maybe need to talk
to some of those services.
But you probably have a lot
of machines and other services
that need to talk
to other services.
And that's ultimately the
problem that Istio solves.
Istio is part of the
Kubernetes family.
It's another open source
project started at Google
that ensures that services
can talk to other services
and do so securely.
It's called a service mesh.
And it handles a lot of the
complexity around generating
certificates and the
certificate management,
the securing of services in both
directions from one to another.
And this is a big problem.
Without something like Istio,
distributing certificates
and ensuring that root
of trust from one service
to another that problem
space is ripe with a lot
of different solutions,
many of which
are brittle and/or
homegrown or just
weren't really designed
for the cloud native
nature of containers.
But Istio was.
And that's exactly what we
hear from customers saying
that everyday they're
using to reduce
the complexity of communication
between those services.
So Istio is often
used in conjunction
with another project,
another open source
project called Envoy.
And Envoy handles the
spreading of network
across a bunch of services,
both inbound from a proxy
and load balancing
perspective, and, well,
it's really about the
inbound at this point.
So being able to handle
service, those microservices
and the traffic going
to those microservices
and route that traffic
appropriately using
load balancers and tied into.
Now there's a lot
of different ways
that you can and will use load
balancers in your clusters
and in your Kubernetes.
Envoy is one of them.
And it's natively part
of this ecosystem.
And these are quite useful
in handling that traffic.
Now serverless or
functions as a service
is another methodology that's
often employed in multi-cloud.
And Knative is another
project that we've implemented
on top of Kubernetes.
So we use Kubernetes as a base.
And then we implement
a serverless engine
called Knative that sits
on top of Kubernetes.
And it can sit anywhere
Kubernetes runs.
And what's important
here is that many
of the serverless
engines or feel certainly
like a vendor lock in.
It's something that's
native to that cloud.
And it's something that you
want to use and you need to use.
But if you're still staying true
to that multi-cloud strategy,
you might be caught
in a bit of a bind.
But Knative is how
you can actually
continue to use functions as a
service or a serverless engine
and avoid that vendor lock in.
This is important
to staying true
to that multi-cloud strategy.
Now part and parcel to
every single containerized
environment, especially
in the multi-cloud,
is a good CI/CD system,
continuous integration
continuous development.
Ensuring that your developers
can write some code,
build that code,
test that, and deploy
that across multiple
clouds, I mean,
you've just blown out
your matrix, right?
Now that you have to be able
to run that same code anywhere,
you need to ensure that you can
test that same code anywhere.
Generally, containers will
handle the portability.
And it'll ensure that
you can move your code
from one place to another.
But you need to be able
to very quickly detect
where someone
somewhere has baked
in an unexpected dependency on
some thing that may not exist
somewhere else at some point.
And that's where something
like Cloud Build or any
of a number of CI/CD,
continuous integration
continuous development,
platforms on top of Kubernetes
can help with that.
And it's all baked very
nicely into Kubernetes,
which handles the scheduling
of the new container that
builds your code and
maybe runs your code
and then spits out
that those test results
into a comprehensive view.
And speaking of view, it's hard
to talk about multiple clouds
without at least thinking about
what a single pane of glass
might look like.
So ensuring that you have
a single pane of glass
across multiple estates, perhaps
on prem in one cloud, cloud
two, cloud three, and in
your own private clouds
is also something that
we hear all the time is
just fundamental to implementing
a multi-cloud strategy.
And so we have that.
It's called the
Google Cloud console.
And from that Google
Cloud console,
which Justin will certainly show
you, from that single Google
Cloud console, you can
see multiple clusters.
You can access those clusters.
You can deploy workloads
and destroy workloads
and scale those workloads
all from a single UI.
And it's a graphical
user interface.
But there are good command
line tools and APIs certainly
for every one of those.
That's just one of our
guiding principles.
And this all works
because that Cloud Console
aggregates all of the
information about your clusters
into a hub.
We call that the GKE hub.
And it's because inside
of every cluster,
there is an agent that
authenticates with your account
and communicates with
that hub and provides
the information, the control
information, the metadata
information about that
cluster, so that the console
can render that for you.
It also catches,
receives the messages
that you post there asking
that cluster to do something.
So it's bi-directional.
It's bi-directional
communication.
And you're able to do that
with a single unified view
across your entire estate
anywhere in the world.
And one of the
things that I think
we see more used than anything
else inside of that single pane
of glass is the log aggregation,
the monitoring of all
of the clusters anywhere.
We provide some really
first class monitoring
and logging solutions in
Google Cloud with Stackdriver.
And we integrate with
a number of others.
You can certainly run your own
ELK Stack, Kibana, Elastic.
And you can run your own
Prometheus or Grafana.
And many of those run
natively, all of those
run natively as containers
inside of Kubernetes.
So once you have
a Kubernetes, you
can deploy those as
workloads inside and then
use those to monitor.
And so being able to do
that with any cluster
anywhere, aggregate that
and process those logs,
trigger on failure,
learn from those logs
and train your
models so that you've
got predictive ways of avoiding
problems in the future,
but doing that across multiple
clouds is quite remarkable.
And that's something that we'll
see here in just a second.
And then managing those clouds,
and especially those clusters,
managing the configuration
across those clusters,
being able to
comprehensively push out
a security policy across many
systems, and combine those
into new and interesting
and secure ways
is essential, and
just really part
of ensuring that you've got
a multi-cloud story that
is secure, and that you're
able to roll out an update
to that policy everywhere.
So config management is
also part of this platform
that I'm describing.
And I'll leave this last
one before we bring this
all together.
We've also got something
called the GKE Marketplace.
And it's a marketplace of
solutions, software solutions,
containers ultimately
that can run originally
in your GKE clusters, the
clusters that you run inside
of Google Cloud.
That marketplace and all of
those solutions, and that's
a factorial not an exclamation
point, all of those solutions
there come together.
And you can deploy those.
They're open source,
third party solutions.
There's commercial software.
There's Google provided
software in that marketplace.
You can deploy those in
new and interesting ways
on prem, in Google Cloud,
and now in other clouds.
And this is all
of these together,
the sum total is
ultimately the thing
that hopefully you heard
about this morning, which
we're calling Anthos.
Anthos being a new platform.
It's truly a platform that
crosses hybrid and multi-cloud.
This is how you actually solve
the hybrid and multi-cloud
problem, modernizing your
applications as containers,
enforcing the security
around the policy,
and doing so at scale
on premises in our cloud
and in other clouds.
That's what we've set
out to build here.
Graphically, it looks
something like this.
I touched on a lot
of these hexagons
over the course of our
little math tutorial here.
But this is how we're seeing
this ecosystem evolve.
This is the
combination of services
necessary to bring
together a platform that
moves from one place
to another and has
that persistent experience.
And with that, I think I'll
leave us with just a thought
that the ethos of
Anthos is that it's
a common language
across any cloud.
It's how things move from
one place to another.
And in that way,
it's a lot like math.
Math is a common language
no matter where you're from.
It's constant.
It's consistent.
It's something that
we can all relate to.
We don't get to change it.
It's not something that we
get to have opinions about.
There's facts.
And that's what we've
set out to build,
a common language that
operates across clouds.
And so at this point, as
in any good Google talk,
we're going to have a live demo
that my colleague Justin here
will lead.
You want this?
Sure.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dustin.
That was great.
[APPLAUSE]
JUSTIN SANTA BARBARA:
All right, I'm
going to try to show
you in this demo
how we put those
formally into practice.
You could say I'm going to plug
some numbers into the equations
that Dustin presented.
Quick outline of what
we're going to do,
because we're going to go
through it pretty fast when
we actually get to it.
We're going to show how
containers in Kubernetes
give us portability
across clouds.
We're going to hit a bunch of
different Kubernetes clusters
in different clouds.
We're going to look at that
single pane of glass, the Cloud
Console so we can get
visibility into our workloads
and our clusters
wherever they are.
We're going to show how
Istio gives us the ability
to understand what's
happening in terms of services
and also gives us connectivity
across those different
clusters.
We're going to look
at logging and tracing
information across
those clusters
again through Stackdriver.
We're going to show
configuration management.
We're going to use
that to do what I hope
is a pretty cool move,
which hopefully wake you
all up a little bit.
And then we're going to dig
into how you can pick services
from around the web,
focusing on BigQuery, which
is a good service
that Google offers,
and also then the marketplace,
which is a way to get services
that other people may offer.
And with that, let's
construct our example here.
So in our scenario
here, we are going
to I might have to debug the
Linux display on the fly, which
is always challenging.
Hold with me for
just one second.
Mirror.
Apologies.
OK?
Yay.
No applause not even for that?
I should say a lot
of these things
that we're showing-- thank you.
A lot of these things we're
showing this week are very new.
So if this does all work,
then definitely that
does warrant a
round of applause.
In our example, we're
going to pretend that we
are an e-commerce retailer.
And we have a fairly
traditional multi-tier app.
We have a web front end, which
serves our web and mobile app
users.
We have a product
catalog component,
which stores the
descriptions of the products
that we're selling.
We have an ERP system that
runs on a mainframe that
really powers our business.
And although we've
put an ERP gateway
in front of that mainframe, that
really keeps everything on prem
right now.
But the web front
end communicates
with the catalog to
serve browsing traffic
and with the ERP system
for the actual orders.
Everything is running on prem
because of that ERP system
on the mainframe.
But we have started to adopt
Kubernetes in the data center.
And we've been
using GKE on prem,
which is great because it will
make this a lot easier going
forwards.
And we are starting
to run our workloads
in portable containers.
Now this isn't really
what people would consider
multi-cloud yet of course.
But that data warehouse is
actually running in the cloud.
We can run BigQuery,
for example,
and tie into cloud ML
and AI functionality.
And so already in this example,
we have some multi-cloud.
We're already choosing
the best capabilities
wherever they're located.
So I suspect that actually if
we go out there, most of you
are already doing multi-cloud
to an extent today.
And similarly, if you think
about how you do DevOps today,
you're probably doing
that not all in one data
center where you're
running your workloads.
You probably have that spread
out across multiple locations.
How we were doing
DevOps here, well,
let's get to some code, right?
So here, we have the code
that powers this demo app.
It's in a Git repository
hosted on Google's Cloud source
repositories.
But you might be using
GitHub, for example.
But you can see our
different components.
We have our front end.
We have our catalog service.
We have our ERP with
the ERP gateway there.
And whenever I push code to
that, we trigger a build.
Here for our CI/CD system,
we're using Cloud Build.
And you can see
I have a trigger.
And so whenever I
push, a build fires off
in the cloud, which is great
in terms of burst ability.
And you can look at some
of my previous builds, some
from more recently
than I care to admit.
And when I dig into it, you
can see that actually this
build succeeded.
And the output of this was
three container images,
those portable container
images which were going
to run on Kubernetes again.
And those are actually
automatically pushed
into the container
registry here.
So here, you can see
for this container
registry for this example, I'm
running on Google's Container
Registry.
But again, you could
run wherever you want.
Note that our Kubernetes
cluster is running on prem.
But our container registry
is running in the cloud.
I think everyone should
be familiar with this.
But it is something
we are able to do.
And that's actually
pretty impressive.
And that's done by
containers in Kubernetes.
All right, and whatever
offerings you want,
GCP obviously has
great offerings.
But you can mix and match
with whatever you choose.
That's the power or the
promise of multi-cloud.
I think that's pretty good
from a developer perspective.
We have a fairly nice push to
deploy pipeline going there.
But let's talk a little bit
about the operational side,
the observability, which is the
right hand side of the slide
here.
So let's look at our
Kubernetes clusters.
So you can see here that
in Google Cloud console,
we have a bunch of
Kubernetes clusters
that appear even if
they're not running GKE.
So we have here a GKE cluster,
which of course, appears.
We have a GKE on prem
cluster, which appears.
And we have a Kubernetes
cluster that isn't GKE at all.
It's actually running in AWS.
We built that using kops
because the team is pretty cool.
But you can use any open source
Kubernetes cluster you want to.
So we'll come back to the
two cloud guys in a minute.
But let's have a
little look at what
we're able to see on
the on prem cluster
through the Cloud console even
though it's running on prem.
So you can see we can
look at our nodes,
get basic observability of that.
But we can also look
at the actual workloads
that are running on prem.
And you can see on
the right there,
we have our three clusters
or three workloads.
But they're all running on prem.
We have our front end, our
catalog, and our ERP gateway.
And that's despite the fact that
this is again running on prem
and we're looking at
it through the cloud.
All right, but let's now
see what other information
we can get.
Let's have our first
look at the app.
So this is the app
running on prem.
You can see the on
prem in the URL there.
And I click around
my example app, which
I invested a lot of time into.
And we've generated
some traffic.
So now we can again
switch to Stackdriver,
where we should now start to
see through Kubernetes and Istio
a lot of the
information that came
in is coming in from our app.
All right, we don't
much as I thought.
But you can see, for example,
that here is a request.
Let's see, a web
request it looks
like that hit the front end.
And you can see that the
resource is a Kubernetes
container.
And the cluster is on prem.
It's running on prem.
And the other one
will presumably
be the back end service
that satisfied that.
Let's see.
Yes, the catalog service.
There we are.
You get all the
logging type views.
Stackdriver has some
nice views on this.
I think my favorite view
is the tracing view.
So if you want to
really understand
what's going on in a multi-tier
service, let's see, a little,
might generate a
bit more traffic.
Let's see.
There we go.
That worked.
All right, there.
So you can see here we
have a trace view, which
is a distributed trace
across the various tiers
of our application.
So we hit the front end there.
And we hit the
catalog service there.
And you can see the details here
that the cluster is once again
on prem.
Because of course, everything
is still running on prem.
But despite the fact it's
running on prem, again,
we're looking at
all that information
through Google Cloud console
in the cloud service.
All right, so this has all
been multi-cloud, but mostly
for running the cluster.
Let's move our data plane.
Let's move our app itself
across multiple clouds.
We have those clusters
sitting there.
Let's use them.
We would like to have the choice
to run our websites somewhere
in the cloud to better handle
spikes as we were told earlier
and to put it in geographies
closer to our customers.
So we've made a great move by
putting our app in Kubernetes.
So it should be relatively
easy to move everything
to the cloud, except for that
mainframe dependency, which
is keeping us on prem.
So we're going to have
to figure something out.
And Kubernetes and
Istio now to the rescue.
So this is our current scenario.
Everything is running on prem.
And we want to do this
slightly difficult trick, which
is to split our
application across,
with the front end
running in the clouds,
in two different clouds in fact,
and tunneling that traffic back
to the on prem cluster.
This is a Kubernetes
environment.
So you could just use
Kubectl to do this.
But you notice I
actually drew a box
at the top for configuration
management with a big arrow.
And that is this is what
configuration management makes
easy and lets you
do declaratively.
So I'm going to show you
just how easy that really is.
We have a code, a source
repo, again another Git repo,
again in Cloud
Source repositories,
but it could be anywhere.
And you can see we have our
clusters described in here.
And we have a
couple of selectors.
This is configuration
management.
We have a couple
of selectors here.
That, for example,
the on prem selector
says, only in the
on prem environment.
Whereas the selector all
says, the environment
can either be on prem or cloud.
And you can see again we have
our three tiers, front end,
catalog, and ERP
described right here.
OK, I will first show that
there is nothing up my sleeves.
I actually don't
have sleeves today.
But there we are.
So we have an AWS URL, which
is obviously not working,
and a GKE.
Sorry.
Did not mean that.
We have our cloud ones,
which are not yet working.
I will now edit the
policy to deploy.
Let's see.
So there are selector on prem.
And all we have to do to
move the front end Kubernetes
applications from on
prem to all our clusters
is to basically
change the selector.
We're going to change
it from selector on prem
to selector all.
We will save.
We will get add.
So there, in case
you missed it there,
changing from selector
on prem to selector all.
We do a get
Commit.
Deploy front end to all clouds.
Push.
We are pushing.
OK, and now if I'm fast
enough, that workloads
view that we had before,
let's see, yes, I beat it, OK.
We should shortly see, it was
not a challenge to beat this,
we should shortly see
the front end deploying.
There we go.
So you can see that
the front end is now
deploying to these two
additional clouds, AWS and GKE.
Of course, it's already
running in on prem.
If I refresh, you will see
that, of course, it's good.
All right, if we hit this,
it's still not going to work.
But we're going to get closer.
So you can see that
we have some errors
about upstream connect errors.
If you know GRPC, this is about
cross service connectivity.
And the reason is that
we haven't actually
made the cloud clusters
able to connect back to our
on prem system.
This is where Istio comes in.
So we just need to
change the end point
for our catalog service.
Istio is able to do
multi-cluster routing.
And we change it from the
Kubernetes internal name
to the name we gave the
multi-cluster service.
We change it.
Commit.
Use Istio multi-cluster service.
Let's push that.
And again, we should
see, if I'm fast enough,
we should see it
start to deploy again
or roll out the
new configuration.
We might miss this.
But let's just go.
Not yet.
Let's watch it.
There it goes.
It is rolling out on
AWS first it looks like.
There they go.
It's running across
all three clusters.
And just one more time.
It looks like we
should be close enough.
All right, we are
now running on AWS.
And we have our website running.
It is going over
Istio back to our
on prem cluster talking
to our ERP gateway
talking to our mainframe.
And we can click
around as before.
And of course, we
can also run on GKE.
And there we go.
And even more magically,
of course, our logging
still works.
Although now, we're able to see,
if we click down and get lucky,
that we are running in
that's still on prem.
We are running in
multiple clusters.
OK, well, I won't keep guessing.
Let's look at the trace view.
The trace view is much
easier to understand.
So here we are.
So let's look at this
one, which took a while.
Let's find a good one.
There we go.
So here we are.
So here we have one that
started off in the AWS cluster
for this top one.
And then the catalog service
was running in on prem.
So we managed to cross that.
So I think that's pretty cool.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, and I will close
that with a quick look
at the other pieces.
So the idea of business
metrics, BigQuery
is a great solution
for business metrics.
So we're streaming our sales
pretty much live into BigQuery
right now.
And if I do this
a couple of times,
you can see if you look very
carefully that the timestamps
should be changing.
There they are.
They are changing.
And of course,
because it's BigQuery,
you can then build
a fancy dashboard.
Maybe.
And I can refresh.
And the order count
should go from three,
and the order count went up.
So this is, indeed, live data.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Two
million during this demo.
JUSTIN SANTA
BARBARA: That's yes.
Exactly.
When you make it up,
you can make good money.
And BigQuery is, of
course, a great system.
But if you wanted to
look at other solutions
from other vendors,
if, for example,
you wanted to get your CRM
data going into BigQuery,
for example, there's a
marketplace solution for that.
You can install
it just like that.
And maybe you have a pricing
engine that runs on Spark.
And so in the
marketplace, there's
a Spark Operator ready to go.
We can choose to configure it.
We can choose to deploy it.
And of course, we can deploy
it onto our GKE cluster.
Of course, we can deploy it
onto our GKE on prem cluster.
But we can also deploy it
onto our Kubernetes cluster
that is running on
another cloud on AWS.
So you just hit deploy,
and it's that easy.
So that is a very quick
outline of containers giving
portability to cross clouds.
Kubernetes, the
single pane of glass,
the console, being able to
see everything everywhere,
Istio being able to power
that multi-cluster traffic,
Stackdriver to give us a view
across all those clusters,
configuration
management so that we
were able to deploy workloads
moving from just one
cluster running on prem
to multiple clusters,
perhaps even more easily than
running a single cluster,
BigQuery for business
metrics, and the marketplace
to deploy solutions onto
any cluster anywhere.
[MUSIC PLAYING]